ich habe auch ein thema mitgebracht ich
also ich widerspreche alexander kissler
leute auch das macht eine kleine sprache
wollte eigentlich nicht mehr aufgreifen
sehr sehr ungern weil ich es liebe
und dem gegenüber eine große menge die
sondern artikel in der nzz und bin
ich dachte mir nehmen es hin sei
gelassen dann wird es schlimmer ich nahm
als verstockt dargestellt wird was ist
eigentlich am meisten fällen immer seine
ja auch virtual signalling also ich rede
meinung und die schönheit ist dabei doch
es hin ich wollte gelassen es wurde viel
so toll weil ich so aufgeklärt bin weil
viel schlimmer das habe ich gestern
und in dem fall will ich natürlich auch
ich kein ausgrenzen will aber man grenzt
ihrer meinung nur ich glaube dass die
nämlich gemerkt ich habe den fehler
gemacht ich habe mir ein fernsehduell
alle aus ich habe jetzt in einem
aufregung darüber völlig überflüssig ist
pfarrbrief er in berlin gelesen liebe
angeschaut das fernsehduell zwischen
viel lustiger als viel besser ist sich
mitglieder mitgliederinnen liebe
zwei zwischen herrn und frau le pen das
darüber lustig zu machen denn die partie
mitglieder mit aber doch so komisch dass
wurde simultan gedolmetscht und der
tatsache ist doch die diese gender
deutsche dolmetscher legt herr noch
das ist doch es gibt schon
mainstream aktivisten über drehen gerade
immer das wort in den mund von den
warum
flüchtenden er hat bestimmt von
haben sie gelassen das freut mich wenn
so sehr dass sie sich selbst eine erste
flüchtlingen gesprochen aber der
ich meine frage ein händler zu stellen
und jeder normale mensch finde das
deutsche zuschauer muss natürlich
erzogen werden es sind flüchtende dann
kann es denn vielleicht sein dass die
ampel die wahlperiode der umerziehung
lächerlich das heißt sich darüber
habe ich eine reportage gehört im
aufzuregen ist eigentlich überflüssig
bayerischen fernsehen im bayrischen
wird wahlperiode der umerziehung das
wenn man wenn man schon hört an wohnende
radio da ging es um streit in der
ist das doch es ist doch normal beim
glaube ich nicht das ist auch nicht der
nachbarschaft und es war immer die rede
anspruch beispielsweise meiner partei
sprachgefühl dass er dass das unsinn ist
von anwohnenden dann dachte ich mir
der fdp also niemand soll umerzogen
ich finde auch wenn nicht öffentlich
warum sind ist eigentlich nicht an
rechtlichen radio höre muss ich immer
wollen dann gibt es nur in bayern an
werden aber ich will mal hier eine etwas
wohnende nein auch in berlin gibt es an
provokante these in den raum stellen ich
wieder ich finde diese komischen
wohnende und sogar die berliner polizei
nehme immer wieder war also wenn wir
pause thema gemacht künstler innen also
jetzt hier sozusagen als mittelalte
twittert mittlerweile von anwohnenden
dass tisch steht die neue binären
männer das thema diskutieren dann geben
wir haben auch eine gender sprache mit
menschen ja dass das auch das steht auch
sternchen mit unterstrich und kleiner
sendezeit auf lamy so das machst du dich
wir natürlich auch unsere wahrnehmung
manchmal auch mit einem mehrfachen kreuz
mal zusammen rechnet ausländer verstehen
unsere werte auch unsere
das heißt man ist von der klarheit in
das ähnlich ausländer oder leute geben
lebensrealität eben wieder ich nehme
sie der wahrnehmung eingeschränkt sind
der benennung übergewechselt in ein
verstehen aber wie gesagt ich finde
aber war dass die generation nach uns
quasi diktatorisches um
darüber aufregen ist unsinn weil ich wie
kommt also gerade sage ich mal sehr
erziehungsprogramm einer elite die einer
gesagt die das tut das wird derzeit so
junge menschen auch was die die
mehrheit gerne vorschreiben möchte wie
überdreht dass sie sich selbst ab so
geschlechterfrage und die definition
sie zu reden hat besonders absurde höhen
auch das was man wie man sich selbst
aber selbst in meinem geld ich sage ja
treibt dieses gendern das komplett
definiert und versteht das wesentlich
auch gebühren java führen weil ich
glaube das ist der entscheidende punkt
unnötig ist bei der außenministerin frau
gelassener sehen als wir beispielsweise
ich glaube jeder kann und soll irgendwie
und ich glaube das könnte auch im
sprechen wir wären natürlich das
werber genauer gesagt bei der
bachelor also ich finde auch seine
hinblick auf den sprachgebrauch gelten
kommunikation ihres amtes es gibt heute
dass da nämlich eine ganz andere
sprache die auch alle menschen mit
nicht mehr kollegen sondern kolleg stern
einbezieht alles in ordnung aber ich
offenheit dafür existiert ich meine
innen außenminister stern ihnen noch
finde schon wenn man wenn man sieht was
natürlich sie arbeiten mit sprache sie
gerade in den öffentlich rechtlichen
einmal minister kollegen kunden sind
auch wir als politiker letztlich auch da
medien gerade so im kinderfernsehen ja
komplett vollständig es ist kein defizit
da gibt es ja verschiedene programme
ist ein tresor tv natürlichen und
also welche sprache dort gesprochen wird
bundeskanzlerin da sind uns ja einig
es ist nämlich nur ein generisches
dass der nicht mit sprache so viele
die hat haben sie ein beispiel für uns
maskulinum kein sexuelles und das
haben wegen dieser einwurf aber wie
ja also gibt es irgendwelche pronomen
besonders tragische und völlig sinnlose
gewählt werden
gesagt ich sehe dass wir
war dann eben bei frau werburg als sie
bevölkerungskreise haben und gerade bei
mehrmals sagte unsere solidarität und
jungen menschen sehe ich dass die haben
das hat einfach nichts mit deutsch
eine ganz andere offenheit dafür und das
unsere hilfe gelten den menschen in der
nichts mehr zu tun und ich also ich muss
könnte durchaus sein dass wir da
sagen vielleicht bin ich auch zu alt
vielleicht nicht ganz richtig aber wir
ukraine
also ich verstehe es nicht ja und ich
da dachte ich mir ach ja die russen die
haben aber
würde empfehlen nur da ehrlich gesagt
da gerade einmarschiert sind auch
völlig in ordnung wenn es ein
auch nicht wollen dass man meine tochter
menschen in der ukraine und den gilt
natürlicher prozess ist weil
sozusagen mit mit einer solchen
gesellschaft entwickelt im sommer sich
deutschen sprache die es gar nicht gibt
unsere solidarität mein mann sagte
der aktion machen denn danach sendung
deswegen auch ford entwickelt das haben
mensch in der ukraine um nicht das böse
wir in den letzten tausend jahren
mit der maus ist noch zu klein und so
wort vom ukraine aussprechen zu müssen
natürlich gehabt dann sprachen sich
viel habe ich ein problem noch nicht
fortentwickelt hat das finde ich völlig
aber aber das ist schon ein thema wenn
denn der ukraine ist grammatikalisch
in ordnung und überhaupt nicht
männlich und das männliche soll offenbar
kritikwürdig aber wenn es oktroyiert
sie ein problem in der zukunft der mit
genau es pflanzt sich ja vor zu sein und
wird von außen operiert wird und wie sie
zumindest auch der sprache aus gepflegt
deswegen ist es schon ein thema wo man
werden das ist falsch das ist unredlich
richtig sagen eine aus einer eliten
sich erstens drüber aufregen kann
vielleicht ich muss aber aufregen kann
sprache sozusagen versucht wird eine
das ist ein um erziehungsprogramm ich
aber was schon fertig einer lösung
allgemeine sprache zu geben
möchte dabei nicht mitmachen ich möchte
zugeführt werden muss weil am ende
nicht dass mich politiker so anreden ich
sprach ist etwas lebendiges das
möchte auch nicht dass die
verändert sich ja und insofern am ende
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien mich so
die schülerin und schüler wissen
anreden bitte bitte hört damit auf dann
irgendwann am ende gar nicht mehr so zu
kann ich wieder meinen seelenfrieden
sagen ich will matschie exploriert die
[Musik]